[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome to this special episode called
how did this stuff get here an inflation
crash course
with yours truly professor brian keating
co-director
of the arthur c clark center for human
imagination and the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at
the university of california san diego
we're going to do a lot of deep dives
into alternative theories
of cosmogenesis so i thought it would be
important to take you on a ride through
the standard
orthodoxy the lore and literature of
what we know
about the dominant aspect the dominant
paradigm of how the universe began
at least up until about a trillionth of
a trillionth of a trillionth of a second
or so
after the cosmic genesis event so it's
probably as far back as we can go
and with tools like the simon's
observatory we do hope to
make progress to perhaps constrain or
rule out perhaps models of inflation
we'll talk about that in future videos
but today i want to give you a crash
course so that you
my beloved audience can have an insight
and understanding of what does inflation
do
why do we need it why is it considered
so successful so much so that it is the
dominant paradigm
in terms of our understanding of the
earliest epoch in cosmic history
and really the answer comes into play
when we consider the question of how did
all this stuff get here
how did the mo the molecules that matter
the matter that matters
us etc get here how did our planet get
here how did our solar system get here
how did our galaxy get here
and so here's an example of what we call
the cosmic wallpaper at least in visible
form
the hubble deep field where every single
speck of light in this image
this magnificent image pointed at the
universe's darkest
corner according to the hubble telescope
director
back in the 90s staring there for two
weeks on end
revealed that every single speck of
light here is a galaxy not a star in the
milky way galaxy
but a proper galaxy itself which could
claim to be
exactly just like our galaxy hosting
perhaps
a half a trillion stars and doing the
math this image subtends only about the
size
of your fingernail held up at arm's
length or maybe even less than that on
the whole sky
so to determine the number of galaxies
there are in the universe all we have to
do is count up how many sizes of your
fingernail would it take to cover the
entire night sky
so this video will go on for about a
couple of weeks so let's go on and count
up how many times we have to move our
finger no we're never going to do that
but instead we do a calculation it comes
out to be about a half a trillion
galaxies
each hosting maybe a half a trillion
stars each of those hosting maybe 10 or
100 or a thousand small bodies large
bodies planetary-sized bodies etc
so the numbers become astronomical and
the question is how did it all get here
and that is the stuff of inflation so
inflationary cosmology is a paradigm
that predicts an early ultra-fast
exponential expansion
of space-time itself sometimes called
the universe
now it has many many features that we'll
explore in this video
and then we'll go into deep dive into
some of the
some of the observations that lead to
our credulity
in something like inflation in future
videos but today i want to present to
you the problems that emerged in the
standard big bang narrative
that inflation does solve in a very
self-consistent
stable way that led cosmologists to
really take it seriously starting in
1980 with guth
and lincoln and starabinsky and others
predicting
more or less similar features which
turned out not quite to work as we'll
explore
and needed to be corrected by up by
future pioneers like andre linde who we
spoke about
in this video the nature of faith to a
physicist
and he is also the co-originator of the
most dominant form of the multiverse
paradigm eternal inflation we'll talk
about that as well
but also paul steinhardt who's been a
guest on the podcast many times has
made fundamental contributions to the
theory of perturbations in the early
universe which lead to structures
like the hubble deep field like us so we
do need to take that seriously
paul has vehemently opposed the
multiverse
outcome of inflationary universe that we
talked about in the faith of a physicist
there'll be more on paul's preferred
cosmological models and where
other alternative models like those of
sir roger penrose winner of the 2020
nobel prize
where those could actually enter in and
be tested against cosmological evidence
so inflation expands the universe
exponentially
in a very very brief period of time
perhaps only a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
in length
it makes the universe the space that we
can see
very small compared to the total amount
of space that there is
in what you could consider the universe
or maybe even predicts
unavoidably the existence of a
multiverse now
it does make predictions many of which
are testable some of which make it
falsifiable
despite some claims to the contrary even
those i discussed
in the faith of a physicist where i did
say this quote that of course if the
universe turned out not to have spatial
flatness that would have falsified
inflation
but not necessarily falsified the
multiverse so it's important to separate
the multiverse from inflation
and we'll make that clear in future
videos so
we'll go through as i do with my
cosmology students as undergraduates
this is a crash course in inflation this
is going to explain to you
everything i want you to know about
inflation in terms of its theoretical
predictions
so that we can then progress onto
experimental tests
of some of these conclusions that
unavoidably come from inflation
so the first conclusion that we talk
about is that the universe
is composed of objects these objects
galaxies quasars etc
they allow us to test the properties of
the early universe
and go back to a very very early
primordial state
those galaxies those quasars etc can
have us
understand how the universe originated
if and
only if inflation comes along with a
mechanism to predict
how the inflationary fluctuations turn
into large-scale structure
like galaxies and quasars that we can
observe another relic that we talk about
here are so-called bbn
or big bang nucleosynthesis observables
these are leftover fossil relics from
the early universe
and some of those persist not only from
the first three minutes after the origin
of time if indeed time began with the
big bang
a topic that we will discuss in great
depth on this channel but also
the universe persisted after that period
of time in a pretty boring quiescent
state for perhaps hundreds of millions
of years
and then it formed primordial gas clouds
primordial gas meaning the very first
atoms the hydrogen helium and their
isotopes deuterium helium-3
those all formed into atomic versions
and some molecular versions
that can be observed via their
absorption spectrum as long as they're
something to kind of
provide light to be absorbed and we'll
talk about that in connection to a late
great colleague of mine
arthur wolf who passed away sadly about
seven or eight years ago
and arthur made contributions titanic
contributions to the study of these damp
lyman alpha systems
and other objects that allow us to
measure the very first primordial atoms
in the universe
those give us credulity in the origin
theory that posited that the universe
underwent
a very brief but intense fusion reaction
in its first few minutes of existence
perhaps and that could be existence in
our current universe emerging from a
collapsing universe
or it could be in the aeon or eon theory
of sir roger penrose and the conformal
cyclic cosmology
all of which we'll discuss especially as
this is the 90th anniversary
of the birth of nobel prize winner sir
roger penrose
but the big bang for all its successes
listed here
has many lacunae or lacks or gaps
some of those involve the fact that the
universe has certain properties that are
unexplained if not imposed by fiat and
cosmologists hate fiat it's another word
for god it's another word for faith
perhaps by
insertion of external conditions that
then determine the initial conditions of
our universe
we'd like to do away with that
especially for many cosmologists who
don't believe in some supernatural
designer
as we talked about with stephen meyer in
the return of the god hypothesis
and we'd like to find a naturalistic or
materialistic origin story for the
universe but we still have to explain
these many lacunae in the big bang
framework one of which is the so-called
flatness problem the universe has what's
called spatial flatness
no matter how big you make a triangle in
the universe from the
something on the earth's surface uh or
just above the earth's surface
any three points uh that's not on the
spherical surface of the earth that's
suspended above it
those three points will have interior
angles whose sum adds up to 180 degrees
you can make those triangles as big as
planets uh three different planets in
our solar system
three stars in our galaxy three galaxies
in our universe no matter what size
triangle you make even going back to the
oldest light
the cmb itself no matter how far you go
back any triangle will always have
interior angles summing up to 180
degrees
and that's mysterious because of all the
different shapes that space could have
as shown on this slide
the flat one the one on the far right
where it's essentially euclidean
is in some sense the least probable
there's only one
shape of space that has zero curvature
and that is flat
and those obey euclidean postulates that
parallel lines don't meet that triangles
interior angle sum up to 180 degrees
but on a sphere you can get widely
varying
interior angles of triangle up to over
900 degrees inside of certain triangles
so it's important to think about this in
the context of cosmological models
how do you get a flat universe from your
cosmic theory
and all theories of cosmology if they
want to contend for the right to claim
a theory of cosmogenesis they all have
to
predict as an outcome of spatial
flatness and we'll explore that for
alternative cosmologies in future videos
the universe also exhibits a lack so
called lack of magnetic monopoles or
other topological
defects we've talked about that in the
past and we will explore that
in some detail as especially pertains to
alternative models of cosmogenesis
and we'll explore that the consequences
of that later on in this video
the last problem that inflation
successfully describes is the so-called
horizon problem
which is the observation that the
universe is isotropic it looks the same
in all directions
not perfectly you won't see a mirror
image of yourself if you look out over
there
but no matter which direction we look
the temperature of the cosmic background
radiation
as explained in previous videos is
identical to a few parts and 10 to the
fourth
so in a few parts of a hundred micro
kelvin really really minut
levels of cosmic um of cosmic
temperature fluctuation
the universe looks exactly the same in
that direction as it does 180 degrees
behind me
even though those two regions of space
and time are separated by some 92
billion light years in other words
they're separated by more
distance then the speed of light times
the elapsed age of the universe
times a very large factor these are
puzzles that every cosmological model
that wants to uh claim the title of
cosmic genesis description
and genus is not meant in a religious
sense but just in the description of the
origin initial conditions of our
universe
they have to contend with that and it's
not clear that other solutions will be
able to
uh other theories will be able to
provide the solutions as economically as
parsimoniously as
inflation seems to have done of course
inflation is not without its critics and
will explore the consequences of
both its critics and its successor
potential successor theories later on
this channel
what is the flatness problem so it was a
problem observed and thought to be
quite fatal at least in the big bang
model in the 1970s and there was really
kind of a paradox
that for almost all time with a universe
that contains matter and radiation
that we know exists in our universe no
other exotic phenomena no other
exotic dark energy which we know exists
or dark matter just
us the stuff we're made of baryonic
matter and radiation that we see from
the cmb cosmic microwave background
radiation
a universe with matter should not
have flatness unless it was exactly
isotropically
established at some extremely early time
so the equations are shown here i'm not
going to get into all the great detail
but the laws of physics can involve a
wide variety a very
coarsely tuned not fine-tuned value at
all but we
seem to choose a value for the curvature
of space-time
the interior angle of triangles always
summing up to 180 degrees
that feature is an observable that has
been unavoidable since measurements done
uh by princeton universities lyman page
and my late uh
advisor uh andrew lang at caltech in the
boomerang experiment with paolo di
bernardus and others that the universe's
flatness established very firmly by
cosmic microwave background experiments
seems to indicate that we live in a very
improbable universe
and it actually gets worse the closer
you go back in time to the big bang
event itself or even just to go back to
the time at which the universe became
a fusion reactor and produce the sorts
of elements that we observed today
so we observe elements at high redshifts
in the form of hydrogen molecules
deuterium etc and we observe those in
clouds of gas that somehow collapse and
condensed and they're not just evenly
uniformly distributed
and the question is how did that get
there well they must have come from a
very hot dense period of time
called big bang nucleosynthesis when the
first elements were synthesized
including their isotopes like deuterium
is an isotope
with two neutrons of hydrogen if we look
back to the when the universe was
creating the deuterium and the hydrogen
the fusion reactor that was putting
together these
neutrons with protons or protons with
protons and neutrons to make
helium protons and neutrons attract each
other via what's called the strong
nuclear force
but protons and protons which should
repel each other and it takes the strong
nuclear force and force between quarks
to cause them to bind together
nevertheless that took place at
extremely high temperatures extremely
high densities
and then the universe cooled off so the
question is how did the universe go from
a density a description called radiation
domination
we can go back to this very tiny
fraction it actually makes the problem
of the universe's curvature as shown in
this equation
10.11 where the equations reference my
friend barbara ryden's
book and these equations are connected
to her book i urge people to get it it's
very readable even for a lay audience
this equation shows that the universe
was even more flat as you go back in
time into earlier and earlier epochs
and the problem gets worse and worse as
you go back in time as close as you want
to
the origin of the universe itself so
something must have established the
universe in a flat initial condition
almost from its inception such that
today
13 billion years plus later we would
observe it with an
uncertainty of about a half a percent in
its curvature in other words the
universe could be
approximately half a percent curved half
a percent positively curved half a
percent negatively curved
although that will be driven closer and
closer to zero as you go back in time so
in other words
the fine-tuning of the initial curvature
of the universe at whatever time period
you want
is almost exponentially challenging to
explain unless you put it in by hand
which we don't like to do we like to
have a physics explanation perhaps from
a theory of astroparticle physics
perhaps from some other theory we don't
necessarily like to impose the
imposition of a mind at work
so the universe had this very very
unusual initial condition of all the
conditions it could take from all the
different radii of spherical surfaces
that could
could have taken on which are infinite
from all the negatively curved surfaces
that it could take on
pringle-shaped hyperbolic shape
saddle-shaped
there's an infinite number of those so
there's an infinite number of positive
curvature
infinite number of negative curvature
and we happen to live in the one
example of flat curvature that needs to
be explained
so the big bang had a challenge to it
and it was realized this was a
significant challenge as early as the
1970s
only a few years after the discovery of
the cmb itself which we'll talk about
and how it originates in the
inflationary paradigm
and what it can teach us via its b mode
polarization that my colleagues and i
study
using the simon's observatory now the
other problem that was very
vexing to cosmologists was the so-called
is the so-called horizon problem
which is this facet that no matter which
direction you look for the left or the
right
forward or backwards the universe has
almost the same exact temperature to
apart
in about ten thousand so a one part and
ten thousand
is about five to ten times smoother than
the highest mountain on earth compared
to the earth's radius so the earth has a
radius of
several thousand kilometers the highest
mountains are 10 a few kilometers
so you're talking about similar or
smaller amounts of fluctuation
in the temperature of the microwave
background compared to the surface of
the earth which is quite ragged and
rough right
but even so seen from space it looks
almost perfectly smooth the universe is
even more smooth it's smoother than the
surface of a ball bearing of a bowling
ball whatever choice
of sphere you could make it's very hard
to make something smoother than one part
or more isotropic than one part and ten
to the fourth or ten to the fifth
so two antipodal points two different
directions you look have
the exact same temperature for all
intents and purposes
how could that possibly be when the
universe was in its infant
state and even when it was in the age of
380 000 years or so when the cmb was
produced
from the combination of proton and
electron to make atomic hydrogen
releasing and allowing photons to freely
propagate to our telescopes today
that epoch 380 000 years after the big
bang it's impossible for the entire
universe to come to thermal equilibrium
at that time
imagine changing the temperature of the
universe right now to make the universe
all the same temperature all exactly
three kelvin
with a fluctuation of 10 to the minus 4
10 to the minus 5.
that'll be incredibly difficult to do
today and it wasn't that much easier
when the universe was a factor of a
thousand smaller
it was a little bit easier but not
nearly easy enough to explain
this bizarre phenomenon that no matter
what direction we look
even two different directions that have
never communicated with each other again
if you're looking at the sun you can
look at the sun
where protective sun eclipse glasses
please take it from your friendly
neighborhood astronomer
it will not be able to be possible for
pluto or for neptune
to receive the information that you're
now receiving if they're on opposite
sides
because earth is much closer to the sun
than is neptune
so it takes light longer to get to
neptune and yet it would be like all the
planets are at the exact same
temperature
established instantaneously we don't
understand how this took place
in the standard big bang that's one of
the things that inflation
purports to solve
observations from the cmb as i say
demonstrate that the universe has
fluctuations but those fluctuations are
tiny
the temperature in one direction differs
from the temperature in the other
direction
by at most a fraction of a milli kelvin
one thousandth of a degree kelvin
over the whole sky once you get rid of
the pernicious dust effects in the milky
way galaxy described in
losing the nobel prize and other videos
that i've discussed on this channel
so we know this from temperature
anisotropy measurements we know that the
universe is
flat from temperature and isotropy
measurements this so-called
doppler peak that is shown here but the
question of why this image of the cmb
this map made from the planck satellite
data
why is this so homogeneous so isotropic
it looks the same in all directions
it's almost too good to be true we
assume the cosmological principle holds
that the universe is isotropic and
homogeneous on large scales
but that's kind of an assumption that we
get from observations but the reason why
we can make that assumption
is not at all clear we have no primary
primordial theory that
mandates that it should be so and
inflation is one of the best candidate
models for it there are actually only a
few different
candidate models for cosmogenesis for
the initial conditions establishing the
formation of light elements the solving
the flatness horizon
and the monopole problem that we'll come
to next
besides inflation maybe a handful maybe
three or four at most
and inflation is certainly the most
successful so why are these regions all
the same temperature maybe it's just a
coincidence
so it turns out that you'd have to have
a coincidence to
make this that is essentially straining
credulity
so here this image my colleague andy
friedman my late great colleague andrew
friedman made
this sphere on the right shows a
tessellation
a triangulation if you will into as many
different circles as you can fit and
still see it on this diagram
and the question is the temperature
inside each one of these little
circles here has almost the same value
to a part and 10 to the fourth or 10 to
the fifth
now this is an exaggeration more
coarsely grained than the image on the
far
left of the screen which shows the
actual cmb but this is just for
illustration purposes
it turns out you can divide the sky the
entire sky any sphere
into over about forty thousand patches
forty four thousand square degrees
is how big the night sky the full four
pi star radians
subtends when converted to square
degrees and you can divide it into
patches as shown on this previous slide
here the peak of the microwave
background occurs
at about 1.12 degrees so in other words
the horizon at last scattering was only
about 1.12 degrees
so roughly there are about 40 000
patches of sky
of the size of the horizon at last
scattering
and they all have the exact same
temperature to within our measurement
ability to within about one part and 10
to the fourth
that's a great puzzle because ideally
are they should be kind of randomized
with much larger fluctuations and yet
they're very very close to one another
and so the analogy that we like to use
is if you have like a dinner and you
have a potluck dinner
and you get together with your friends
you invite 40 000 of your closest
friends to petco park here in san diego
and you say bring a dish you don't tell
them what to bring
and they all bring that same disgusting
marshmallow
thing over here a potato salad or
whatever that is i wouldn't want to eat
it i don't recommend you do either but
the point is
if all 40 000 of them are so brilliant
the same
exact dish you would suspect some kind
of conspiracy at work
and that's effectively in the cmb
context saying that there was
a equilibrium event that occurred
prior much prior to the surface of last
scatterings production
earlier than 380 000 years or so after
the big bang
and there was something that
synchronized all the temperatures to the
exact same temperature
within a tiny fraction of a degree of a
millikelvin
and that was synchronized and it turns
out you have to synchronize it much much
earlier than the time of the cmb
because there's not enough time at 380
000 years to get the conspiracy to work
you have to set it much much earlier and
inflation is
one of the mechanisms by which this
conspiracy can be had
another example that we sometimes use is
if you have these islands that have
never been
visited they all they are widely
separated and yet they speak
portuguese or something you'd have to
think that
sometime in the past they were visited
by the same uh
portuguese uh you know colonists and
and so it becomes hard to dismiss it as
a coincidence and so you look for a
physical explanation
so the horizon problem is this very
statement that this pattern here
although it looks kind of modeled
and and variegated it's actually very
very exaggerated so that you can see it
actually the fluctuations are very small
the universe is very smooth
at this time 370 000 years after the big
bang
so all these regions of the universe
were out of causal contact pretty much
unless they're within 2.3 degrees or so
of one another on the sky
and again if you look in the direction
right in front of your nose in the
microwave background and look 180
degrees around
you still get the same temperature
coincidence even though those are
much much greater separation than 2.3
degrees it's a great mystery
here's a diagram that andy friedman made
with his colleague david kaiser and
jason galicio who's a professor
at harvey mudd college uh david kaiser
mit has been a guest on the podcast
and it shows what i call light cones
intersecting in the past
and the question is how far back do you
have to go so that two events
share the same causal history meaning
you could turn the temperature in this
corner of the universe and turn the
temperature in that corner of the
universe
and allow them to get by the time you
make an observation to the same
temperature
without having to violate any laws of
physics such as faster than light
information transmission so andy did
some of these calculations i'll leave
this on the screen
and it turns out to be incredibly hard
to do beyond this 2.3 degree separation
and of course this diagram is not the
scale but andy can
could easily show and you can easily
show just by inference
that 180 degrees is some 90 times almost
harder than 2.3
degree separation so there's really no
explanation
other than some of these other models
that establish a prior period of thermal
equilibrium
to explain the so-called flatness
problem it's a major major prediction of
the inflationary paradigm
so this is the horizon problem we
describe the flatness problem
these slides i'll leave up on the screen
so that you can pour over them in the
depth that they deserve so these circles
are projections of the light cone back
to a surface of blast scattering again
andy is indicating they're not the scale
the last problem that counted originally
as one of alan guth's major motivations
was to explain the absence of so-called
magnetic monopoles
so if you combine the fact that the
universe began to fuse elements together
three minutes or so after the big bang
you can unavoidably extrapolate to
earlier periods of time when it was too
hot to form
uh quarks or form uh protons certainly
and that temperature was high enough
that you could actually go through
what's called a phase
transition the phase transition is very
similar to
a transition from ice to liquid water or
from liquid water to steam
going from one form of matter to another
and typically at the boundary between
say melting ice into water there'll be
some surface some chunk of ice that's
broken off
where there'll be a boundary and that is
sometimes called a topological defect
uh for for interesting reasons we're not
going to get into that but it's a phase
boundary between liquid water and solid
water
i.e ice and that boundary has certain
properties
that in these theories in which you
unify the strong weak and
electromagnetic
forces of nature produce what are called
monopoles
so an ordinary magnet you know a
horseshoe magnet or a bar magnet
has a north and south pole if you break
that horseshoe magnet in half
you don't get a north pole and a south
pole you get a north pole and a south
pole and a north pole and a south pole
in other words you've doubled the number
of north poles and south poles and for
maxwell's equations we know that
monopoles never occur in nature
but the question is why if the universe
underwent this electroweak unification
this phase transition
in which magnetism and electricity are
still unified at
temperatures associated with even with
very high temperatures like the sun or
something like that
but if you go back to 10 to the 12th gev
trillion times higher
than what cern's lhc can probe if you go
to those extremely high energies
electromagnetism and the weak nuclear
force were one
force and perhaps they were combined
with a strong force as well as what's
known as a gut
we've talked about theories of
everything and i joke sometimes we think
about the toes more than we think about
the guts
and that is sort of this this notion
that we want to do outdo what einstein
did and we have many videos with
eric weinstein garrett lisey uh stephen
wolfram and others that purport to come
up with other ways to unify gravity and
quantum mechanics
and of course we did this video on loop
quantum gravity as well
which is a candidate theory for quantum
gravity if not a theory of everything
so uh the electro weak phase transition
and the gut theory
uh perhaps occur at temperatures
associated not with 3 kelvin or 3 000
kelvin or 3 trillion kelvin
but uh something like 10 trillion
trillion kelvin
or more and so these are just completely
out of the reach of any kind of
particle accelerator or you know or
bunsen burner that you may have access
to
and so it's many many orders of
magnitude in fact it's coming close to
the uh what's called the planck energy
um and
that may be the ultimate discretization
energy the ultimate
highest energy that anything could ever
achieve so we'll explore some of the
consequences
of all these but inflation is a paradigm
which can purport to explain
the monopole problem the flatness
problem and the horizon problem
we have to take it seriously we don't
have to accept it
in you know as it is we can propose
modifications it too
just like the big bang had lacuna so too
does
the theory of cosmic inflation and some
say those lacunae are fatal
in other words some say the existence of
the multiverse and the fine-tuning
that's inherent in inflation
requires either some imposition by fiat
of a low entropy state or
the addition of a of some period of
collapse
contraction or perhaps these infinite
expansions
of the aeon theory of cosmic conformal
cyclic cosmology
we'll talk about those more for now this
has been your crash course
and the problems of the big bang that
lead us to believe in inflation
next time we'll talk about the actual
nuts and bolts of inflation and i'll
give you a crash course
in the ins and outs of what a
professional cosmologist does as a
theorist and then how we're trying to
probe these predictions
including some new predictions using
cosmic microwave background polarization
experiments
such as the simon's observatory stay
tuned for more signing off now
for into the impossible i am your
fearful host dr brian keating
chancellor's professor of physics at the
university of california
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
you enjoyed this video and you
definitely want to check out this
playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena
click here and hear my conversation with
juan maldasena of the institute for
advanced study
enjoy and don't forget to subscribe for
more amazing content